i capelli madonna ma niente ma
chissenefrega se molto dipende
particolari bene tutti i ragazzi
benvenuti a questo video sono quello
quei capelli è lui è quello con i baffi
siamo col green screen male male io
moronato adesso ho messo meglio però chi
se ne frega perché abbiamo oggi una
reaction di youtube che invece lo sanno
fare youtube e non che sono messa in
onda rischi in store tosi porca put
inerente ok
ecco le sue prove siamo qua per farla
reaction i nostri amici di space valley
perché un mese non più due più due
milanesi due mesi fa sui mandanti ma a
bologna da questi ragazzi i magnifici
volevo vedere il video montato siamo
finalmente giunti al giorno in cui
uscito il video io sono molto curioso e
anche perché giampiero era con me quindi
io ho vissuto da spettatore adesso non
sto rivivendo da spettatore ma montaldo
montato da bellezza e mi fece la legge
fiduciato e c'è una delle macìe per
prenotarsi che obiettivamente uscita del
sangue bello bellissimo senza indugio
allora di non presentare nostro andrea
avviato sta roba
se mi stavo pagando nelle mutande perché
ero di elio mentre lo sta facendo st
robben solo sentendo tutto vedendo tutto
quando ha parlato di sangue io vi
annunciamo già morendo lui era lì che mi
anima da far sanguinare
speriamo e grazie a un bell'inizio dai
serbatoi della mia vita adesso avrà
voglia di entrare
signore e signori oggi è qui con noi
fabi
ma lei anche pensavo che non si ripeta
esatto io stavo per dirti sta roba tutto
spaventato che entry invece gli
immigrati ancora lì lo youtube con più
iscritti d'italia attualmente si però
per un signore che potrebbe però sì sì
sì spero ancora somma veicola sono
ancora tra 5 minuti no però ancora tutto
10 a rispondere prima manche a tutti
piace giocare forse molto spesso abbiamo
delle bacinelle piene di kakà davanti
hai riportato una cacca si fa niente
ma io voglio capire così chi ha cercato
sta roba assuma amazon che l'hanno
comprato e ste cose cosa hanno cercato
kakà è da parecchio che ne ha fatto
stupire da tantissimi di loro è appunto
il gran lavoro che c'è dietro c'è una
persona che è andata suo amico preso le
cose che ha avuto l'idea bensì specie
quali sono turley noi questa ragion
stiamo facendo in cinque minuti
addirittura una video dura 22 ott
non lo so però le pesco lo stesso ma che
poi che poi tra l'altro io mi ricordo
che qua tutti quanti quando facciamo
soltanto uno faccia la domanda poi uno
per prenotarsi faceva anche sigla
stasera si ma che tanto era talmente di
finale qua mar la presa con la mano e
come faccio a toglierla dalla canna ma
se io la presa
qua ci vuole un ingegnere nostro tempo e
scusate sarà difficilissimo parquet per
la guardo dei credibile imprevisti miope
scola come niente nessuno ma questo
traguardo e sarete lì che è che lo
staffettone dove la tua più quella
licenza bancaria francese estraibile
ciclo ma questa cosa come comitati e
severino lo sapevano con un pallone al
2005 tu che dovresti del 2008
guardate ragazzi non funziona perché io
guardavo nel suo entusiasta rosa perché
con lucida attorno al cesano in mano poi
si impazzire fa peccato ragazzi perché
sta per succedere una cosa che non è
stata ripresa
adesso vedremo di sicuro è che adesso
faccio una cosa che non avrei mai
pensato e non effetti quando la foto del
tuo padre eccolo ecco però però è però
non si vede che è quello
io io io sono uscito e ho iniziato a
correre intorno al quartiere c'è proprio
sono uscito dagli studi però però non si
vede comunque ragazzi immaginate se
corriamo a ben strano per riprenderlo
lui che voleva fare sta roba del
contrabbasso
proviamo a telefonare aveva ancora
definiscono lo ha detto proviamo
telefonata con il televoto gruffudd
paiono a 450 500 come non è giusto non è
non è non rende giustizia ma siamo
veramente corso lui con la videocamera
io senza cose abbiamo guardato su dati
veri caterina meritati della star o la
meritatissima giusto grandelli a9 sarà
impossibile questa era quella che non ha
no era tardi ci sarà pronto come di
questo sì lui era al sito sale le scale
che questa cosa aspetti ma aspetto stai
qua ti aspetta allora vedere queste cose
lo fa diventare attivo come lo era nel
video quindi ma sarei sta facendo io
come cachet mi sono fregato e no non
sono stato pagato però ho fregato questo
perché mi serviva per la tastiera quindi
o questo me lo sono portato poi a casa
loro non lo sanno che sei stato il mio
cachet per il video ha il duster spray
che magari non lo serviva anche per una
normale carichiamo c un po perché siamo
tutti ma veramente come ha ricordato è
fighissimo è veramente mettiamo perché
qual'era visti l'anno così dosso impasto
no ma io non ho studiato che è male
malissimo renzo si sia fatto un affare
[Musica]
e io l'avrei sbagliata sta roba
meno male che non c'è mai provato da ros
a roma non ci ho provato ho capito che
non era cosa filati e quindi ho
disturbato ma poi non avrei azzeccato la
domanda risposta un bel like gli avrei
detto la intro lauree pure io iniziali
ne sbagliatissimo quale però male che
l'ha vinto nelson ma non abbiamo davanti
un vaso pieno di casa tus per essere
vera medi che fanno le legioni di
vincere questa qui in italia questa che
state per vedere è la challenge di
lorella che voi vedrete mai nella vostra
vita c'è proprio vita incredibile
ragazzi lorenzo male non avete idea di
quanto in questo momento guardami si sta
scavando solo voi non vuoi farlo ma
perché c'è un pò un trauma dei cactus
perché quando ero piccolo mi hanno
andare va uno che andavo lì con le mani
era un pò studio dei fatti stimato però
andava lì la domanda non è da lui o
colei che frequenta abitualmente un
canale youtube malissimo ma quando tu
non capisca una famiglia si ma è
iniziata riaccendere tutte
mi sarebbe piaciuto se devo rispondere
rispondi no si chiama gente che
frequenta youtube abitualmente un canale
youtube uno script ricordato ieri con
non me lo ricordavo le famiglie ed aree
di pregio bellissimo io guarda guarda il
mio scatto di terrore dire la verità
ancora mag efraim inbar la fiammamonza
dai boss finali dal soul su belli
poi off screen mi hanno tirato un
petardo
cosa dobbiamo fare dovete sbucciare la
patata e si prenota chi ama donna il
fatto è che io dice io avevo oltre alla
manualità da camera ma io ho più paura
di tagliarmi c'era orribile sono
inguardabili lei ancora cesare cesare in
credito di un potere sui poterla
ricoperta sta roba incredibile ragazzi
non so fare niente
veramente veramente ridicolo non so
capace pasteur ove c'è chi giura mi sono
impegnati si era veramente difficile
ragazzi questo è mio massimo sono andato
al 34
e qual è la domanda storico abbiamo una
torino che tipo di minaccia con due di
capri non ho mai visto questa fare qui
in mano sì però
il possibile io ve lo giuro non era più
facile certamente a scendere tutti ma
centenario cesare veramente un realmente
perso io da me ha perso nell'unico punto
che è fatto di irrigazione sua nonna è
vero che la parola credibile ma ce stai
facendo tutto nella valle si è già
uscito e 15 prima questo video
no ragazzi allora non vedo rivedere
anche quello che è bellissima provato
anche questo senso non invitate fvg a
casa vostra
cosa diciamo alcuni video aiuto sapersi
se adesso adesso adesso lo so vai ad
esso è infatti adesso lorenzo
rimostranze non ricorrenze rimostranze
una cosa che dicono che le riverenze
vari loro rimostranze mais massa esiste
maledizioni rig riverenze e poi
l'italiano non lo so sono studiati dai
ragazzi
va bene chiunque video dai e non un
telecomando non fare niente questo video
dura una vita perché non si può chiudere
quindi ok basta è stato molto differenza
vivente arriverebbe a fare merende
andiamo a river plate ragazzi come
chiudono il video di space valle ragazzi
salotto nella valle uscirà tra poco non
vedo la rivedere anche quello che dire
io mi sono divertito spero anche tu sei
stato proprio un bel belli si è
immediatamente una delle migliori cioè
collaborazioni mai fatte veramente di
ragazzi incredibili passate la canalis
paice valle i ragazzi e
nulla speriamo mi invitino alla prossima
senza il cactus però niente ragazzi si
provvedesse piaciuto bellissimo per la
parte nostra perché va beh c'eravamo noi
dove vi sia piaciuto
un bacione un bacione ragazzi space male
e noi come sempre ci vediamo allora
prossimo video a riverenze
[Musica]